[Musik]
schimmel morgen und wir möchten über
diese fragen mit der bildungsministerin
bettina stark watzinger sprechen frau
stark watzinger sie sind selbst mutter
zweier söhne wie haben sie die
vergangenen jahre muss man mittlerweile
ja sagen die politik erlebt guten morgen
herr alzheimer ich bin mutter von zwei
töchtern finde ich auch töchter habe und
ich habe meine töchter sind 23 und 25
ich habe es eher im studierenden bereich
gesehen weil in schule und in den
hochschulen ist natürlich durch das
schließen der schulen und hochschulen
sehr viel bildungs ausfall eingetreten
aber auch psychosoziale probleme beide
sind ganz wichtige lebensphasen von
jungen menschen die brauchen freunde die
brauchen ein umfeld die müssen sich
entwickeln die müssen was ausprobieren
und das hat gefehlt und das müssen wir
weiter möglich machen deswegen müssen
wir alles wunder schulen und hochschulen
auf dem bleiben was sagen ihnen ihre
töchter dass sie da mal auf den tisch
hauen sollen in der bundesregierung dass
sie wieder in die uni können dass da
auch präsenz möglich ist dass die regeln
fallen sollen also wir müssen ja wir
dürfen die krise nicht immer nur im tag
heute planen deswegen müssen wir auch
darüber nachdenken wie wir wieder aus
dem chor ohne einschränkungen
herauskommen aber als sicher ist dass
wir jetzt erstmal die schulen offen
halten müssen das muss alles getan
werden vor allen dingen müssen wir mit
den hygienemaßnahmen aber auch mit dem
impfen dass wir in die schulen bringen
müssen dafür sorgen dass dort ein hoher
schutz da ist und das zweite in den
hochschulen ist wirklich die frage ja
meistens so durchs raster weil man denkt
das sind schon sind ja auch erwachsene
menschen aber eben noch in der wichtigen
lebensphase und hier muss man sagen dass
das die belastung sehr hoch ist dass in
dem psycho sozialen nach der nachfrage
nach beratung aber selbst mit der
präsenzpflicht klappt es ja teilweise
immer noch nicht in deutschland zum
beispiel in berlin wurde das wieder
diskutiert warum können in anderen
ländern alle regeln fall wie in
großbritannien zum beispiel da machen
selbst clubs wieder auf und wie kriegen
sie nicht mal in den schulen vernünftig
ja mich hat das überrascht was in berlin
passiert ist weil wir ja auch gesehen
haben dass die kmk ganz klar gesagt hat
präsenzpflicht ist eben
bildungsgerechtigkeit und vor allem die
art wie kommuniziert wurde ist natürlich
für schulen und für die 11 für die
familien ganz schwierig kurzfristig
umzusetzen wir haben bei uns im land
eine situation die in anderen ländern
etwas anders gelagert ist wir haben eine
ältere gesellschaft und in dieser in dem
teil der menschen über 50 über 60 ist
auch die impfquote noch nicht so hoch
wie in anderen länder das macht es etwas
schwieriger aber wir haben uns als
bundesregierung ja das klare ziel
gesetzt kein lockdown sondern mit
differenzierten maßnahmen so viel
gesellschaftliches öffentliches leben
wie möglich machen aber nochmal warum
geht in großbritannien so viel und bei
uns selbst in den schulen noch so wenig
wo ja auch masken pflicht zum beispiel
weiter geht viele zuschriften die wir
bekommen bei bild ist dass sich eltern
beklagen und sagen die kinder so viele
stunden mit masten das geht nicht mehr
viel sehen sie da ja ich kann das gut
verstehen das ist eine hohe belastung
gerade für die für die kinder ist macht
was in der kommunikation aber es ist
immer noch besser als keine schule zu
haben keinen unterricht zu haben
großbritannien ist etwas vor uns in der
welle der mikrowelle deswegen sind wir
noch ein stück weit hinterher und
trotzdem heute schon an morgen denken
und die vorbereitungen treffen wir
überlegen wie gehen wir raus das sind
die ersten schritte dann auch die man
treffen muss um maßnahmen abzubauen das
ist jetzt die aufgabe der nächsten wahl
noch wäre das so weit dann erleben wir
unser großmutter nicht dann erleben wir
unser großbritannien habe ich das wüsste
würde ich mich sehr freuen weil wir dann
glaube ich alle auf einen bestimmten tag
hin leben könnten aber wir sehen ja es
wird erwartet dass wir mitte februar den
höchsten punkt haben von omikron und
dass danach die inzidenz und dann wieder
steigen hospitalisierung 's rate und
intensivbetten sind ja zum glück nicht
nach gelaufen in dem maße insofern denke
ich dass wenn der zweiten februarhälfte
dann wirklich anfangen können und
überleben können die was machen dann
fällt die meisten fürchte er uns einmal
da würde ich keine wetten darauf
abschließen weil ich finde dass ist noch
das niedrigste um schutz zu haben weil
eben dort die möglichkeit des
miteinanders besteht aber trotzdem an
gesundheitsschutz die kanzlerin hat in
der pandemie immer wieder persönlich
dafür gesorgt dass schulen geschlossen
wurden denn den ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen warum war das zu glauben sie
und wie sehr hat diese politik den
kindern geschadet zu beginn der korona
pandemie hat man sehr stark auf den
gesundheitsschutz wert gelegt man hat
die die nebenwirkungen die schlimmen
nebenwirkungen noch nicht in dem maß im
blick gehabt und deswegen ist es gut und
richtig dass wir als bundesregierung den
kindern jetzt auch eine stimme geben ich
weiß das ist nicht einfach viele eltern
sind auch in sorge das kann ich gut
verstehen aber die bildungsgerechtigkeit
und vereinigen das was an psychosozialen
schäden steht entsteht ist dann doch so
tiefgreifend dass präsenzpflicht mit
schutzmaßnahmen mit dem impfangebot die
bessere alternative ist man hat manchmal
das gefühl deutschland ist ein
kinderfreundliches land wenn man sagt
andere länder machen früher auf kümmern
sich mehr um diese folgen ist das so
haben sie auch das gefühl also in dieser
bundesregierung ist es ganz bestimmt
nicht so wir haben alles getan haben
auch im sinne des
infektionsschutzgesetzes angepasst hat
keine flächendeckenden schulschließung
mehr stattfinden und haben auch mit den
maßnahmen hygienemaßnahmen alles dafür
getan dass vor ort eben kinder auch den
respekt bekommen den sie brauchen wenn
sie von respekt sprechen ist es wichtig
dass man dann als politikerin auch
selbst diese erfahrung hat dass man
kinder hat kann man politik für kinder
besser machen wenn man nicht kinderlos
ist
seine eine interessante frage es hilft
natürlich aber wer als politiker sind ja
im austausch mit den menschen wir sind
ja nicht nur politiker für eine partei
wenn man in regierung ist sondern man
ist er dann für die bevölkerung für die
menschen da und insofern sind wir ja
auch im austausch also es ist natürlich
gut wenn man die chance hat das direkt
mit zu bekommen aber man kann sich das
auch durch das durch den die
kommunikation vor ort kann man auch
erfahren
die situation ist
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
waren immer wieder davor dass es eine
durchseuchung eben nicht geben darf und
spricht von möglichen longo wird folgen
da hat man das gefühl er ist blieben die
schulen dicht dann hat man gesagt nein
man kann nicht öffnen und jetzt fühlen
wir uns wieder erzählen dann halt ganz
gefährlich da könnte longo gekommen was
macht das mit ihnen also wir haben ja
ich bin ja nicht nur
bundesbildungsministerin sondern bildung
und forschung und wir haben sehr früh
ministerium auch zucker ohne geforscht
haben ja auch die impfstoffherstellung
und entwicklung befördert jetzt auch
eben die medikamente die therapien gegen
corbett und sie haben auch eine studie
jetzt oder ein forschungsprojekt zum
thema long gut aufgelegt das ist etwas
womit wir arbeiten müssen wir sehen ja
zahlen jetzt aus anderen ländern erste
erste
indikationen welche altersgruppen welche
vorbelastungen zur long geht führen das
ist eine frage der sollten uns offensiv
stellen denn darüber werden wir in
zukunft noch sprechen müssen aber ich
bin guten mutes mit guten therapien und
der aufmerksamkeit schulen
aufmerksamkeit für das thema können wir
auch da gegenmittel schatten heftig
debattiert heftig umstritten ist die
impfung und auch gerade die frage ab
welchem alter möglicherweise das ganze
kommen soll wie sehr sind sie da als fdp
wortbrüchig geworden nein wir führen
eine debatte die geführt werden muss in
unserem land auf der einen seite die
freiheit des einzelnen auf der anderen
seite natürlich der freiheitsbegriff in
einer gesellschaft und das sind zwei
dinge die müssen zusammengebracht enders
muss abgewogen werden und wir sehen ja
dass ein drittel von regulären
behandlungen im medizinischen bereich
gar nicht stattfinden kann weil eben die
das gesundheitssystem so stark belastet
ist das ist kein freibrief für eine für
eine impfpflicht aber es ist ein abwägen
dass wir machen müssen das ding bin ich
froh dass wir bei uns in der partei eine
meinung breite haben ich denke das hilft
dem demokratischen diskurs und deswegen
bin ich auch froh dass wir es aus der
mitte des parlamentes aber es war doch
ein klarer wortbruch man hat das video
gesehen von christian lindner dem
bundesvorsitzende ihrer partei der im
wahlkampf gesagt hat ich verspreche
ihnen im pflicht wird nicht kommen dann
hat der eine eine frau dort auf der
straße zu ihm gesagt ja aber was ist
nach der wahl und da hat er gesagt nein
auch nach der wahl wird nicht kommen wie
wollen sie das den menschen erklären
dass sie so ein versprechen machen und
als fdp chef das dann wieder
zurücknehmen deswegen haben wir gesagt
wir wollen das nicht fraktions abhängig
machen sondern der freien entscheidung
des einzelnen abgeordneten über ein
leiblicher ein wortbruch das ist ja die
einzelnen entscheidungen jedes
abgeordneten hohes gut bei uns in
unserem land aber wenn da ein fdp chef
sagt die wird nicht kommen und auch nach
der wahl nicht kommen dann ist das ein
wortbruch wenn er sich dann danach dafür
ausspricht sie müssen sehen dass wir
jetzt mit omikron beziehungsweise vorher
mit delta ganz andere situationen hatten
aber deswegen ist es gut dass wir die
nur einige und kommunen ist ja schlecht
genau das steht ja dafür dass irgend
licht kommt deswegen ist ja gut dass wir
die breite debatte führen und keine
schnellschüsse machen
machen sie also haben wir im herbst
gesagt die impfpflicht muss jetzt
unbedingt sofort kommt diese ist ja
nicht da wir diskutieren darüber und
werde ihre portale
ausgesperrt bundesvorsitzender die
medizinischen kenntnisse oder
erkenntnisse die neuen werden wir
einfließen lassen ich gucke mir die
debatte wirklich ergebnisoffen an und
werde dann meine entscheidung treibt wo
stehen sie momentan wenn sie sehen dass
omikron schwächer ist dass die
intensivstation eben nicht voll laufen
also dass diese ganzen argumente die es
vorher gab ihm nicht so stimmen wie man
gedacht hat und dass man sich eben
wieder anstecken kann auch mit krone
also das erste argument dass das gegen
die ansteckung gehen soll also wo stehen
sie persönlich momentan wenn sie jetzt
abstimmen müssten impfpflicht ja oder
nein zum einen zeigt das dass es nicht
so trivial ist eine impfpflicht
einzuführen wie der eine oder andere
sieht das vielleicht auch vorgestellt
hat ich bin der meinung dass wir mit
blick auf die struktur unserer
gesellschaft wir haben ja ebene ältere
gesellschaft als in anderen ländern uns
überlegen müssen ob wir durch eine
gezielte gruppe die wir schützen noch
mal daneben mehr freiheit für alle
anschauen aber da schaue ich mir noch
einmal an vor allen dingen auch mit dem
was die wissenschaftler dazu sagen es
gibt rechtliche aspekt es gibt
medizinische aspekt ist das
gesellschaftliche aspekt in stadt jetzt
wo stehen sie ich bin auch ergebnisoffen
ich gucke mir aber die altersbezogene
schlicht noch mal ganz besonders genau
an die fdp hat gesagt zum 20 märz 22
sollen alle maßnahmen aufgehoben werden
wird das passiert das ist eine hoffnung
die man haben kann und wer mit also das
nicht versprechen dass sie kassieren wer
ist beste denken aber wenn corona eine
andere abzweigen nimmt wovon ich nicht
ausgehe warten müssen positiv denken
müssen wir uns auch auf schwierige
situationen vorbereitet sehen aber den
optimismus und die vorbereitung auch
wieder hoffnung durch dass für uns ist
jetzt an der tagesordnung wenn wir uns
anschauen wie sie diskutiert haben und
auch ihre parteikollegen diskutiert
haben in der opposition da wurde über
frieden gesprochen da wurde über
diskriminierung von ungeimpften
gesprochen die impfpflicht wurde
ausgeschlossen haben sie die liberalen
wähler betrogen
wir haben offen diskutiert und wir
diskutieren auch heute offen sie sehen
ja die bandbreite die wir haben
diskriminierung von ungeimpften ist
nicht an der tagesordnung aber wir
müssen natürlich dem trauma dem land das
sie regieren wir haben
sicherheitsmaßnahmen damit wir keinen
oder vorsichtsmaßnahmen regelungen
getroffen damit ja keinen kompletten
locker und haben müssen aber zeige plus
zum beispiel die das ist eine
diskriminierung von umgehend geht auch
darum dass die impfung nicht nur ein
schutz von sich selber ist sondern auch
ein teil zur lösung
beiträgt weil eben die
krankheitsverläufe milder sind und die
ansteckung kürzer ist insofern ist es
ein teil die man dazu beiträgt dass
gesellschaftliches leben stattfinden
kann der schulen offen bleiben können
und deswegen finde ich sollte man
darüber diskutieren ich kann nur jeden
ermutigen sich impfen zu lassen und
mikron verläuft deutlich milder als
delta auch bei kindern warum haben wir
dann noch masken masken tests quarantäne
regeln für kinder was soll das ganze ja
wir haben natürlich spät angefangen die
kinder und jugendlichen zu impfen bei
den studierenden ist ja eine hohe
impfbereitschaft das muss man sagen das
muss man auch wirklich loben aber wir
haben ja spät eben gerade bei den
kindern von 12 bis 18 uhr bei den
jugendlichen angefangen und deswegen
müssen wir gas geben und die angebote
stärken damit der volle schutz da ist
damit eben dann auch hier sicher ist
dass krankheitsverläufe oder zumindest
die chance oder das ziel dass die
krankheitsverläufe milder sind und die
ansteckung geringer werden letzte frage
mit der bitte um eine schnelle antwort
können sie für wand können sie den
schülerinnen und schülern versprechen
dass alle maßnahmen fallen werden so
bald wie möglich und vor allen dingen
freue ich mich auf das gespräch mit
schülervertretern und mit den vertretern
von studierenden um direkt mit ihnen zu
sprechen was gemacht werden muss
herzlich dann bettina stark watzinger
und mit diesem spannenden gespräch und
der frage was bei der impfpflicht
passiert und vor allem wie die fdp
reagiert hat